lot of respect for science let me tell
you why okay 104 marriages are sexless
meaning that the man hasn't gotten sex I
mean you could argue the woman too but
usually it's the woman withholding the
sex
um I think it's in three months
something like that and that's
classified as senseless
so if you're not sleeping with your
husband
[Music]
um
and a girl says I'm gonna she sees an
opportunity she's like oh this guy could
protect provide um I I think he would be
a good boyfriend or a good husband can
you really be mad if he gets a side
chick
if if you're not sleeping with them
anyway
nope sorry I know you would say no you
agree with me okay I agree yeah I
wouldn't be mad exactly like go for it
honey yeah like if she saw an
opportunity I'm like God what do you
think
uh I don't know about that I think that
he should be loyal because they're mate
so what
it's it's not all about it's not all
about that is it it's it's about lots of
other things that if if a woman's not
sleeping with you there's obviously a
reason for it so you've got to get to
that reason before
what if it's a stupid reason
what's the stupid reason like I'm
insecure with my body yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
I feel like it I don't
um I don't know I think that is a stupid
reason and and to not sleep with someone
because of that is is mad but I don't
think it's okay for a man to go and get
us a side chick just because of that
where's the Loyalty at like when we get
in a relationship I'm getting in a
relationship with you thinking that
you're gonna respect me be loyal yeah
but he went in the relationship thinking
he was going to get sex
would you buy a car without an engine no
so like what if you what if you bought a
car and then boom three months in the
engine's gone
he's like he's like [ __ ] I gotta get to
work why am I call moving I've got a
steering wheel kids
I've got all everything why are my car
moving because women seem to forget that
the engine in the relationship is that
coochie that's what we got to work for
that's what we do 20 hours 40 hours 60
hours for so we can come home hear
nothing and be blessed with God's
greatest creation
I get that I just still don't think it's
all right for a man to just go elsewhere
I used to I used to kind of think like
that then I changed my mind yeah it was
four days
like four days it's not a long time when
you think about it because honestly I
wasn't even mad that she was a side
chick I was like you're just being lazy
with it like I swear to God like if
you're gonna be a side chick compete are
you already in that role compete try to
win no but sometimes
what I watched that episode her issue
was that she said she wouldn't trust him
because then she thinks that he would
then just well I'm just saying she was
already in love like she was basically
in love with him so I'm like you're
already in that situation is like being
side chicks though because there's
benefits to being a side chick are you
saying that a side chick should be
content
with being the side chick that whoever
you're speaking about you saying she
should just be content no I said she
should compete she should try to win
right I'm not saying it's good odds I'm
not even 10 I'd recommend it I'm just
saying like I I can't fault someone if
you're if you're and I'm not saying I
don't know that his girlfriend's
situation whatever but it's like I know
the numbers behind it and I know there's
a lot of men in marriages that they
can't get out because she can leave and
take half your [ __ ] and she so and she
can take your kids with you and then on
top of that like he's basically chained
in because one out of four marriages are
sexless so she cannot sleep with him and
then he doesn't want to get a divorce
because she's going to take half the
[ __ ] so it's like if he's in there's a
lot of men that are in those situations
and it's and it's like if one out of
four men are in those situations and
another girl comes in and sees this like
I just I gotta respect the game that's
all I say game
it's the game you shouldn't have
neglected your like because girls will
always talk about you know he cheated he
cheated and like go on social media and
cry about it but we never talk about why
did he cheat what were you not doing
that he cheated and the thing is women
do this all the time since I can
probably remember because we know it's
it's a sacrifice as men we know if we
want to have a great career we've got to
sacrifice relationships and family if we
don't want to be rich and famous then
we'll have a great family and we'll have
you know we'll have great relationships
so we've all heard the story of the
husband who works too much the husband
who's always on a business trip yeah we
what's wife doing with her PT with her
personal trainer with Jose that does
yoga what's going on Tom Brady and
Giselle come on this is and women have
been doing this for time they make
movies about it it's called Sex in the
City yeah
it's a blockbuster who was buying those
tickets
he was going to watch that and entertain
that that's a lot did you go to the
cinema to watch Sex in the City no did
you no but if you watched it though no
are you sure promise all right
thank you
so you agree though and you don't you
you think he should be loyal even if
she's not sleeping with him yeah if if
they're ready for a divorce and and you
know that's where the relationship's
going or whatever and he's already
fallen in love with someone else fun but
he he shouldn't just go and get a side
chick because she's not sleeping with
him I just feel like what what happened
to loyalty for for how long do you think
so
um as in how long could she not sleep
with him before him if a man doesn't
want to lose his assets because
especially in the UK I've heard divorce
laws are really bad here like a guy can
lose up to 70 percent of his assets in a
divorce and if he says you know what I
want to keep my stuff and she's not
having sex with him how long should he
deal with that until he cheats or should
he just be in that forever
um I don't think he should be in that
forever obviously that's not fair at all
but the if if she's not sleeping with
him because they aren't actually or or
they're heading for a divorce anyway
that I think that's that's different he
shouldn't just go out and find it
because she's not slept with him for a
couple months I don't think that's all
right no way so don't you think that a
man's gonna think right if my woman is
not sleeping with me who is she sleeping
with
because I mean
if you if you flipped it
and I wasn't sleeping with you
for three months I would be thinking I
would be thinking I'll be thinking what
I haven't stuck it on you for free I
ain't walked past you in the kitchen and
smacked your ass nothing for three
months you're gonna be in my you're
gonna be on my phone you're gonna be in
my phone you're gonna be in my phone
figuring out who's riding it because it
ain't been me
no I've I think no she's like Fairborn
I agree I think that I would think you
know if if I if he didn't sleep with me
or whatever I'd be thinking who is he
sleeping with but it I don't think that
that makes it all right it's still not
all right how does that make it okay
look I'm not even saying it's okay I
just respect it that I heard blessing
can I tell the Zimbabwe story you told
me yeah yeah blessing was telling me the
other day that what happens is so I
don't know if you guys a lot of men are
leaving
um the West to go find wives so they're
going to like places where women are a
little bit more traditional in the East
and and blessing tool makes he's from
Zimbabwe that um fam like um the
Zimbabwe men here will be dating a girl
or married to a girl and then basically
they'll go do business in Zimbabwe for
two months and those girls there are
traditional and they want they look at
that man like that is their meal ticket
so they treat him like an absolute King
and just like worship the ground he
walks on and like they ruin like
families and while I don't recommend
that it's like if if she's doing
something you're not
I just respect the game
this game
modern women have lost the game yeah
they don't have no more games and just
sit there look pretty you think if I put
a BBL on I'll get my life changed no
you're nothing like great grandma you're
nothing like Grandma that was cooking
pot pies making meals for the boys
getting the dominoes ready like playing
the music there's so much little things
that modern women are losing out on with
an experience by just feeling entitled
for some reason yeah well and it's just
like because it's just common like a lot
of guys will say like one in four
marriages are sexless on top of that
like girls gain a bunch of weight after
they get married and then you know they
stop sleeping them with them after they
have the kids they don't cook they don't
clean they don't do the things that like
men want and so it's like if a girl
comes in if you're not doing your job as
a wife like how can then leave the girl
don't don't have a side chick I I would
agree with you I know what you're saying
if the government didn't trap them I
would agree with you if they weren't I
mean imagine been working for 20 years
and she could take 70 percent of that
and the kids I think what it is a lot of
the time when when
um
when it is like a secless marriage
situation yeah a lot of the time that is
kind of done on purpose because I think
a lot of
um I think a lot of women know that that
is leverage so they're not necessarily
some sometimes it is done on purpose I'm
not gonna do this okay because you're
not doing this so I know that this is
something that I I know you want I'm not
going to give it to you but when it's
done with that kind of mindset it's not
worth it it's not it's definitely not
worth it on for for the for the woman
because it's gonna again it's gonna make
he's not gonna make that guy do anything
go oh it shouldn't really because again
that guy shouldn't be should be sort of
bending over for for the punan yeah I
feel sorry for them guys to be honest
yeah
paying the bills and not getting nothing
at home dry Sahara Desert blue balls
Peak it's Peak
S I don't think about it though they
must feel like trapped
it's like it's like it's not a very good
advert for marriage is it to be honest
it was it's like you you would feel like
you've been tricked because the
beginning of the relationship you were
like humping like rabbits yeah and then
halfway through uh you know suddenly
where's this person going do you know
what I mean that was that was jumping on
me all them years ago like well I'm
going for it yeah do you know what it is
here women have like they're like innate
players so it's like once they've
completed their mission of I've got your
time and attention they go dead
as many of you know I was just banned on
on talk and we monetized on a
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible